I understand that you did not audition
any lead actors all right yeah my first
film was like all auditions I don't
think if there was anyone in the film
that did an audition for it and this
time around because i had my first film
to sort of show for myself I could just
kind of go directly to people I liked
and I also learned i love the casting
process like i love i mean we had to
shun some people like some of the day
players some of the smaller parts you
know but but everyone whose work i'd
seen for me I feel like I heard a story
recently about Chris Cooper auditioning
for a movie and I thought what would you
need Chris Cooper to audition for like
he's this amazing brilliant actor like
what is he gonna show you in an audition
room I think would feel like a big
studio movie so the network or not the
the studio needs in to audition but
still I felt like he's like one of the
greatest actors of his generation like
what would you ask from him that he
hasn't already showed he can do but for
me it was a similar mind state of that
of just like there's these actors that
are just loved like I'll I thought Corey
Stoll just took it took you know um
midnight in Harrison so many great
performance isn't it and here you had
this guy who really had very little
previous film presence before and stole
the whole movie and just like two scenes
and it was like that feeling was like I
while I want to work with that guy like
no matter what and that he wanted to do
the part I'm like what am I gonna have
to you know we talked about it of course
I think you need to have for me I feel
like for especially lead parts and
you've seen someone's work before and
you generally trust them or know what
they're going to do with it for me a
meeting is more important if you can
talk about the character in a way that's
simpatico then you're going to be able
to work together that's that's more i
love the audition process just with this
movie i felt like if i had the
opportunity to get people like corey or
denis o'hare who I've seen he's done
every you know he's done everything I've
seen him do from like you know small
parts of big studio movies like being a
crazy vampire entry but like he could do
everything so what is it that you know
for me that there's power and casting in
terms of trusting someone's previous
work but like Jonathan I hadn't seen the
lead I hadn't seen him do much he didn't
really have many film credits to his
name he was mostly known from stage and
TV and I'd see him on Glee a little bit
but I didn't really know much about him
and then we met and he had all these
qualities I was looking for just from
our sit down at lunch and we also got
along a lot which when someone's mean
every scene of the movie and working
every minute of every day the
personality plays if you
each part independent of talent but then
he was doing a play downtown with Alfred
Molina where was just the two of them on
stage for two hours and he was so he was
like so good in it and I just thought
well if he can hold his own against
Alfred Molina for two hours without a
break on stage like I'm sure there's
nothing this movie's gonna throw his way
that's gonna be more challenging than
that and um and I think the instincts
were right he was better than I
anticipated like I'm really it's the
thing I'm proudest of most of the movie
is work in it um and I think no I think
it's going to surprise a lot of people
who were familiar with him before but
also introduced into a lot of people who
weren't familiar with him and and
because he's just really likable and has
all these sort of great star qualities i
hope that when people see the film you
know that they really love him in it so
getting to the part where i'm sure a lot
of directors don't want to be in how do
you tell someone they're not right for
part that's always a touchy thing maybe
you like them as a person maybe they
were brilliant actor yeah it's been it's
tough it's weird because I I've stayed
friends from since we did a lot of
auditioning and easier and practice i
just read friends with some of the
people that we got close to casting but
ultimately didn't and it was I usually
stay in touch with them because I loved
them so much in fact the audition one of
the things I like about auditioning is
finding all these great people that
might not be right for the movie but you
keep them in mind for the next one and
and for me it's weird you have someone
can be it's hard because it's an
argument you always end up having having
half with producers because they're
gonna be like well are you know or
executive types like well there's this
big game and we'd love to get a minute
said well yeah he's great actor but he's
not right for this not you know I don't
always believe the biggest name is the
best name but to go back to even the
someone who might just not be right for
the party it can be really hard because
just cuz you love someone and maybe you
really want it to work with them doesn't
mean it's always gonna gonna fit right
and and it's just I don't know what it
is I Casting I think only is instinct
you know I really really believe that I
mean I think there's responsibilities
sometimes financially but I think if
you're making a movie relatively cheaply
you just need to trust her and sticks on
it a hundred percent I really believe
that it's it's hard because I think I've
always if I've ever argued with
financier is the most thing thing about
the most it's casting because I think at
the end of the day if you don't have any
money and you don't have any time as
long as you have a camera and like a
decent-looking space if you have great
actors like your
have something amazing and so I've
always fought for independence and
casting you know I always have and of
course it makes maybe a movie more
challenging to sell or whatever but at
the end of the day I can stand by it
more you know I think independent film
has become kind of fueled a lot by the
casting process so you get all these
smell movies or kind of big names or
like people who haven't just like hyped
names I don't I try not to serve into
that at all I try to just cast someone
based off what I think of them but that
can create a lot of opposition to honest
moment did it on this moment didn't I
think people really excited everyone
kind of knew that Jonathan was a place
to do something like this and everyone
knew Cory was you know coming it was
before any of us had seen house of cards
but house cards has elevated him so much
but we all knew he was in a place for
that and same with I mean dennis is just
he's one of those guys that's been
acting for so long and done so much
amazing work that for me I just didn't
even for me it was like it's got to be
look I just love I love I love his work
so much and I think everyone loves him
in the film you know so it was there was
never any you know we got lucky but also
that's because I passed on a lot of
opportunities to make this film without
casting control so I made sure that by
the time I did get to make it it was
with the understanding that i was mcast
this film the way I wanted to cast it
and I fought for that and had to wait a
long time for that but it ended up being
worth it I don't know if you saw Shawn
Baker's starlet I haven't seen it yet
but I'm darling I know Shawn andabas
idea yeah and and he cast one of the
this older lead the said could Johnson
just by seeing her at the YMCA yeah
that's why I heard that it was it was
like him and i know blake the producer
he works or two this is like saw her and
thought she'd be right for it she's
excellent yeah and the chemistry between
she and Reever just was amazing so was
there anyone like that where you just
kind of saw them in passing and then
what we're just I've always wanted that
you know us hear those stories I've
always wanted that like what I almost
did once in my first film I remember we
were having trouble finding the right
person for the lead and Brian who ended
up coming in for is like the last person
to come in not because we do want to see
him because he was busy I think she
didn't hurt locker at the time so he
just wasn't even available however one
time I was that like did Warner Brothers
commissary and saw someone that I was
like he looks right for the parking
Sicily and cooking my producers let me
just go see if he's would be interested
and he ends up being like no no I'm not
actor but it was one of those things
were like that's like my dream to just
like find someone like that it's never
exactly we just see someone and you know
that they're right that's never it
hasn't happened to me yet but I
certainly want that but it's important I
think would be great but what I do try
to do the variation is I try to always
even if I see someone that got a
commercial I think was like really
interesting or kind of funny like I try
to look them up or someone who might
have a bit part in a you know I've met a
lot of a lot of actors that way where I
just I see them in like one scene of an
episode of a show and think they're
really interesting and then you bring
them in front and you meet them and then
you end up really liking them and then
sometimes they end up like taking their
careers end up like exploding off
without you having you had any influence
on that but I think it's good to be
aware of that and to try to write those
names down and I have like a huge
running list of just people i think are
interesting that way never haven't
totally i did casting anyone from it yet
but I've met a lot of great people that
way
you